what I would I would say you're very
handsome man like you've seen healthy
healthiest [ __ ] you have an organic
garden your backyard no no no I got some
[ __ ] I grow okay a little bit a little
bit not a lot get a lot of from the
store yeah that's really me and I don't
buy meat from the store like I get I get
to opt out of factory farm because I
have a lot of blog name stuff my house I
have definitely still bought meat from
the store i buy way less of it and I eat
meat almost every day yeah
highway less but I'll still go to a
restaurant and order steak yeah I feel
like this is something the Tribune
people probably heard before but it's
like the feeling of eating while gaming
is just different it's way different it
tastes different it's better for you it
feels different it feels different for
my body yeah you know I mean I have I
remember watching this thing about Ted
Nugent once I was like how's that guy
got so much [ __ ] energy he's like 65
years old he's eating deer every day all
day all day
I mean his love or hate that guy there's
a lot of power to his diet he's a good
guy you get to know him he really is
like people are saying to me like you
have a job to do join the podcast I love
him how about that does he say things
that I agree with 100% on no one ever
sat and talked to uncle Ted which you
know [ __ ] I worked at the NRA for a
while I'm like I used to get assigned to
the Ted Nugent talk that he gave at the
NRA annual meetings like I was a writer
for the NRA and like worked for that
digital websites and I would get
assigned to like the Ted Nugent seminar
at the NRA annual meetings I would go
and sit in the back with Ted no blood
brother and he it's crazy he's not fake
he ain't faking that that ain't like
something he just puts on for the
cameras that's Ted and but he is smart
man like he is as you found out on that
podcast which I thought was amazing like
that dude is sharp as they come you know
what also he's reasonable and open to
new information you don't think RJ - I
turned him on to marijuana yeah you did
okay this is a first of all he's using
CBD on a regular basis in fact if you go
to Ted Nugent official go to his [ __ ]
his Instagram he was actually he was
advertising jambo CBD that I hooked him
up with yeah everything was happened
some serious knee pains he's that up you
know he was told telling me about his
days of rock-and-roll jumping off of
amplifiers and he destroyed his meniscus
this is her shot I ran into him like
three years ago at a concert and went
backstage and we were chatting and he
had huge ice packs on each one of his
knees I just had surgery and yeah I
don't know what the surgery was for but
it like he clearly he was clearly in
pain and like he just looked you know
rundown but then we went out in the
crowd he came onstage he looked like a
25 year old rock guy yeah
he [ __ ] he's a hard-working man yeah
I mean when when the time comes and
lights are on that guy goes after it and
people like to it so you support with
the racist things you said it is like it
no unfortunate you know whatever the
[ __ ] he said that you didn't like that
either he shouldn't have said or maybe
you didn't understand what he meant or
maybe it's out of context anything that
hurts anybody's feeling and I don't
support it but guess what we're all we
all have unfortunate things about us
that's just the fact of being a [ __ ]
human being and one of the parts one of
the things that we're doing when we're
screaming out and calling out someone
and want someone deep platformed and
dismissed and never never to be heard of
them again we're worried we're part of
us are worried that that's going to
happen to us we're worried that we would
ever exhibit that sort of reprehensible
behavior or language and we want to we
want to put a stop to it in ourselves in
other people we want to eliminate it
from our society and culture we want to
do it harshly and ruthlessly and we're
terrified that it's gonna be done to us
yeah you know and there's a lot of
people that make some [ __ ] really
terrible mistakes and I think there's
got to be some sort of a path to
redemption I really I really believe
that always because I meet you know in
hunting I'm certainly don't meet the
caliber of folks that you have in this
room but like I meet these people and
hunting and then I run around in the in
these circles and people are saying this
person thinks this and you've seen that
Instagram post I don't believe in that
and like knocking people down yeah and I
just think I know that person that's a
good person you know and maybe he's not
he or she is not depicting this in the
way that you like it in this instance
that's a good
well-meaning person people are more than
capable of mistakes and we should be
more than capable of allowing them
Redemption and